modern birds are an insanely diverse
group from teeny tiny hummingbirds to
the giant flashy cassowary from the
fuzzy looking Oddball kiwi to Penguins
the Speedy swimmers of the sea birds are
pretty amazing they have a global
distribution live in the coldest and
hottest places on Earth migrate
incredible distances and even fly higher
than the peak of Mount Everest they were
such a special group the back in the
1700s Corollas Linnaeus assigned them to
their very own group AVS
you might be wondering what place a
lesson on birds has in a course on
dinosaurs
but it is the fact that birds are
dinosaurs that makes them key to
developing a deep understanding of
pretty much everything about dinosaurs
even those that went extinct over 66
million years ago
birds are dinosaurs because when we plug
them into cladistic analyzes of
vertebrate Evolution the most
parsimonious position for them is deep
within Dinosauria if we put on our
evolutionary or phylogenetic glasses
just like paleontologists do we Define
Dinosauria as any animal that is the
descendant of the most recent common
ancestor of the theropod Megalosaurus
and the ornithopod Iguanodon it doesn't
matter what the size or shape of an
animal might be it doesn't matter
whether it lived millions of years ago
or right now over the past 50 years the
most important development for dinosaur
scientists has been this simple truth
birds all birds fossil Birds modern
Birds big birds small birds flightless
birds and yes even swimming Birds they
are all dinosaurs
back when Linnaeus originally defined
AVS there were a suite of
characteristics that distinguished
flying birds from all other known
animals
you can probably list the few most
obvious ones yourself
birds have beaks instead of teeth
they have feathers gorgeous coverings
that are great for flying for display
for warmth and even for waterproofing
they have wings made of specialized
feathers hanging from their arm bones
and they have feet that are often good
for perching
if we peel back the surface features of
birds and take a deeper look inside
their bodies a few more important
features of their Anatomy highlight
additional specializations their bones
are very thin with Hollow spaces on the
insides a feature that makes them quite
lightweight one of the critical bones in
the wrists of birds is a little Half
Moon shaped bone called the semilunate
carpal that allows them to fold their
wings and helps power the flight stroke
at least for flying birds their bony
sternum is Broad and keeled forward to
form what looks like a sharp blade to
accommodate powerful flight muscles
when you have a chicken breast for
dinner you're eating those mussels
birds don't have a long bony tail like
lizards but instead have a short little
stubby tail made a fused tail vertebrae
bones are fused in other parts of their
skeleton too
birds have fewer individual skull bones
than most other reptiles and their hip
elements get fused together seamlessly
into a structure called the sin sacrum
one of the most important bone fusions
is found in the clavicle called the
furcula this is the wishbone the same
bone that you may pull and make a wish
with at Thanksgiving
beyond their bones Birds also have a
unique Anatomy that supports their
special way of breathing
instead of a set of soft and pliable
lungs birds have rigid lungs that are
connected to a series of air sacs some
of these air sacs lie within the
cavities of their bodies and some of
them perforate their vertebrae and Bones
to invest these Hollow elements with air
helping circulate air and also
contributing to reduced body mass for
flight
take a deep breath in and out
as mammals we think we're pretty awesome
but when we breathe we leave a ton of
air hanging out in our relatively wimpy
lungs birds breathe very differently
instead of an inhale exhale pattern they
use a circular pattern their initial
breath bypasses the lungs and fills air
sacs where some oxygen is extracted the
next breath pushes that air into a
different set of air sacs where more
oxygen is extracted the next breath
pushes that same air into the lungs
where even more oxygen is drawn out as a
result birds are far more efficient
extractors of oxygen than mammals are
which might help fuel their high
metabolism rapid growth rates and maybe
their warm-blooded bodies
one of the predictions that Darwin made
about evolution by natural selection was
that if his theory was correct we should
find transitional forms in the fossil
record creatures that could not easily
fit into existing taxonomic categories
because they exhibited characteristics
of more than one group
just two years after Darwin's
publication of Origin of Species just
such a specimen was discovered in
Jurassic age solenhofen Limestone
lagerstadt the first hint was a single
fossil feather preserved as a carbonized
impression amongst amazingly preserved
fish invertebrates and plants
soon after an entire skeleton emerged
from the Rocks a skeleton with the
toothed skull and long bony tail of a
reptile but with the feathers and wings
akin to those in living birds this
remarkable new animal was called
archeopteryx a name that translates to
ancient wing
Sir Thomas Huxley who gained the
nickname of Darwin's Bulldog touted the
discovery around England as great
evidence for Darwin's new theory of
evolution
over the next hundred years many more
specimens of the mysterious archeopteryx
would be uncovered at solenhofen each
specimen was preserved in different
postures and with different details
leading to a much more complete
understanding of the animal's
distinctive Anatomy
so many features pointed to a link
between dinosaurs and birds but for
years one critical element appeared to
be missing where was the archeopteryx
wishbone this tiny fragile little
element embedded in the muscle of the
shoulder joint appeared absent in the
assembled archeopteryx specimens for
many scientists at the time the
perceived lack of a circular in both
archeopteryx and theropod dinosaurs
eliminated the possibility that these
two groups of animals could be related
and it changed the way we viewed
dinosaurs for years to come as overgrown
slow-moving cold-blooded beasts with
their tails dragging on the ground
this idea of the overgrown reptile
dictated the perception of Dinosauria in
both science and the public until the
early 1960s when a young Yale
paleontologist named John Ostrom made a
discovery that would introduce the way
we now think about dinosaurs
one afternoon in late August 1964 John
was prospecting for fossils in the
Cloverly formation an outcrop of early
Cretaceous sedimentary rocks in southern
Montana
the field season was drawing to a close
and Ostrom was thinking about where his
team might begin their work the
following summer
eyes to the ground suddenly Ostrom and
his assistant Grant e Meyer noticed a
black shiny bone sticking out from the
rocky slope a few feet below them
they slid down to the bone-bearing
Horizon and realized that they were
seeing a large sharp clawed dinosaur
hand
they were so excited that they dropped
down to their knees and began plucking
bits of Rock Away using only their hands
and pocket knives
as the specimen was exposed they started
to spot the sharp serrated teeth of a
theropod dinosaur
they returned with excavation tools the
next day and continued digging exposing
a foot that would change the study of
dinosaurs forever
this three-toed foot had two toes with
ordinary claws but the innermost toe was
tipped by a large sickle-shaped deadly
claw
the slashing Arc provided the fodder for
the name that Ostrom would eventually
bestow upon his new theropod he called
it dinonicus which means terrible claw
the next few years found Ostrom and his
team continuing to excavate the Cloverly
site for two more summertime field
seasons and three long years studying
and reconstructing the detailed anatomy
of at least four dinonicus individuals
recovered from the same area
in 1969 Ostrom published his work and
ditched the cold-blooded Dino stereotype
in favor of a quote fleet-footed highly
predacious extremely agile and very
active animal sensitive to many stimuli
and quick in its responses end quote
one of the undergraduate student members
of the 1964 Expedition a young
paleontologist named Robert bocker
contributed a drawing to a company
ostrom's paper
the illustration depicted Deinonychus in
full Sprint with its terrible claw
uplifted and its sharp clawed hands
curled ready for grasping prey the
discovery the paper and the imagery
would launch a revolution in dinosaur
biology that we paleontologists call the
dinosaur Renaissance
Ostrom continued his research and during
Museum visits in Europe in the 1970s he
realized the similarities in the
detailed articulations and anatomy of
the skeletons of dinonicus and
archeaptricks this detailed anatomical
study prompted Ostrom to revive the old
hypothesis championed by Thomas Huxley
that birds were descended from theropod
dinosaurs like dinonicus
he laid out more than 20 different
anatomical similarities between
archeopteryx and theropod dinosaurs
Ostrom spent his later years out of the
field instead working at the Yale
Peabody Museum he always believed that
the best discoveries are made in Museum
Store rooms and for the next 30 years of
his career he published paper after
paper detailing the connections between
dinosaurs birds and the evolution of
flight
other major contributors to the dinosaur
Renaissance included the work of Robert
bocker who published the dinosaur
heresies in 1986.
this book pushed the ideas of the active
agile dinosaur with an almost
Evangelical fervor
at the same time Jack Horner a Montana
native who never graduated from college
was busy finding the first North
American baby dinosaurs a Ness
suddenly not only were dinosaurs more
active like birds they were also good
parents
Jack published his book digging
dinosaurs a pop science summary of his
work in 1988. as the 1990s got rolling
the Canadian paleontologist Philip Curry
began working with Scientists in China
who revealed the very first discoveries
of feathered dinosaurs
John Ostrom saw these first feathery
fossils at the annual Society of
vertebrate paleontology meeting at the
American Museum of Natural History in
1996.
for those of us in the room witnessing
his emotional reaction to seeing the
literal confirmation of his work was a
moment never to be forgotten
today there is no question that birds
share anatomical features with Dinosaurs
because they inherited them from their
common ancestor they represent a true
evolutionary group birds are dinosaurs
it's not just a fun catchphrase it's the
truth
it turns out that since ostrom's
pioneering work many of the features
that were historically considered
specific to birds gets smeared deep down
into the dinosaur family tree
let's talk through some of the most
compelling bits of evidence linking
these groups of animals
[Music]
feathers might at first glance seem
pretty simple but they're actually
complicated biological structures
they're built of a central rakis with
projecting barbs linked together by
barbules and tiny little structures
called hooklets the connections between
the barbs is partly what dictates the
shape of the feather from the flight and
tail feathers of birds to Downy fluffy
insulating feathers to bristles and
decorative phyla plumes
our fossil record indicates the first
feathers evolved in a specific group of
theropod dinosaurs called solorasaurs
this group includes Tyrannosaurs
ornithomimids theraxenosaurs and config
nathids dinosaur feathers are often
fuzzy and Downy looking
even big dinosaurs like you tyrannus
with eight inch long Downy feathers look
fluffy and cute
in a few dinosaurs like the tiny
microraptor primary feathers are present
on the arms and legs
in other dinosaurs like Velociraptor
direct evidence of feathers is the
presence of little bumps on the ulna
called quill knobs where feathers
articulated with the arm bones
the deeper we dig into the dinosaur
family tree the evidence for feathers
gets less common while the evidence for
a wider array of special skin
adaptations gets even more interesting
Paul Barrett my colleague and keeper of
Dinosauria at the Natural History Museum
in London studied a sample of dinosaur
species where skin Impressions exist and
map them out onto an evolutionary tree
animals like sauropods hadrosaurs
ceratopsians and chylostores and
stegosaurs likely didn't have feathers
we have a lot of skin impressions of
these animals and all exhibit scaly skin
in a few rare instances other kinds of
skin adaptations have been recovered in
dinosaurs like the specialized quills on
the tail of a little ceratopsian but
these unique cases map out
parsimoniously as independently evolved
another example of convergent evolution
in which dinosaurs have lots of cool
options for fancy adaptations of their
skin
the data support the idea that feathers
first evolved in a subgroup of theropods
it's likely that the original feathers
were Downy and not used for flight but
instead served other functions like to
keep warm or for display
[Music]
remember all those features of Bones and
birds that we discussed at the top of
this lesson it turns out that many of
these features can be found deep down in
the dinosaur family tree some so far
back that they Branch into a much
broader group of dinosaurs for instance
the wing folding flight stroking bone
called the semilunate carpal is also
present in the subgroup of theropods
that includes dinonicus and Velociraptor
a group known as the manoraptora
this little Half Moon shaped wrist bone
changes the way that these theropods can
move their hands instead of just up and
down the semilunate carpal allows side
to side and rotational movements this
bone is the reason that the Raptors in
Jurassic Park can open doors
and though wishbones seem to be absent
in theropod dinosaurs for many years we
since realized they were present all
along they've just been misidentified in
many of the theropods that have them
now we have fertile from early Jurassic
theropod dinosaurs indicating that this
feature is a pretty ancient part of the
theropod body plan
what about those short little Tails of
birds some theropod dinosaurs that are
more closely related to birds also have
them
our recently discovered species of
overwrapped taurosaurus the first
theropod to exhibit a short little bony
tail made up of fused tail bones just
like that of modern flying birds
even further back evolutionarily the
vertebrae of both theropod and sauropod
dinosaurs exhibit perforations on their
surfaces and internal Hollows that
correspond to the pneumatic vertebrae of
birds today this is cool because it also
points to the presence of air sacs
similar to those connected to the lungs
in modern birds in sauropods the
presence of such aerosacs lightens the
estimated body mass of these behemoths
by as much as 10 percent
[Music]
if Hollow vertebrae are consistent with
the presence of air sacs this is a good
indication that avian style airflow may
have been present in both theropods and
sauropods pushing the origin of this
Innovation Way Back to the base of the
siriskyan family tree
as you'll recall this novel way of
extracting oxygen is linked to high
rates of metabolism in living birds
which correspond to a warm-blooded
lifestyle and super fast growth rates
analysis of the microscopic structure of
both sariskian and ornithiscan dinosaurs
indicates High vascularity and cell
densities disorganized bone mineral and
abundant bone remodeling all of which
are consistent with a more mammalian or
avian growth strategy than reptiles this
may indicate Baseline metabolic rates
that were elevated in all dinosaurs and
points to birds inheriting at least a
bump up in growth and metabolic
strategies from their ancient dinosaur
precursors
the preservation of soft tissues in some
fossils also supports the connection
between dinosaurs and birds beta keratin
the unique protein that builds feathers
beaks and Claw sheaths and modern Birds
has been preserved on the sickle-shaped
toe cloth sheath of the 66 million year
old theropod from Madagascar and work on
Tyrannosaurus Rex fossils has revealed
the presence of amino acids that are
consistent with those of modern chickens
as modern evolutionary developmental
biologists work hard to decipher the
genomes of living birds they've also
found evidence of extinct genes in
living chickens that in earlier
evolutionary history would have built
teeth and long bony tails in this way
the Genome of living birds preserves a
molecular fossil record that allows us
to test hypotheses about the ways that
mutations changed gene expression
millions of years ago to result in novel
morphologies
finally just for fun we also have great
evidence for birdie behavior from
dinosaurs one of my favorites is the
discovery of an oviraptorid sitting atop
a nest of eggs the original discoveries
in Mongolia of these dinosaurs
associated with nests prompted early
workers to name the first such theropods
oviraptor a nod to the idea that these
big bad meat eaters were stealing eggs
from the nests of unassuming herbivorous
dinos imagine the surprise of the
scientists who finally popped open one
of the well-preserved fossil eggs to
find a baby oviraptor inside contrary to
the name these egg thieves might
actually have been great parents sitting
atop their nests and caring for their
unhatched young
and we can't forget about the duck-sized
juvenile troad onto theropod discovered
in Liao ning Province China this tiny
fossil is complete from head to toe and
preserved an Exquisite three-dimensional
detail the hind legs are folded beneath
the body much like the roosting posture
for modern Birds the head is tucked
under one of the four Limbs and the tail
wraps forward circling the body
scientists propose that this Dino was
preserved while it was asleep
pose prompted the name my long which
translates to soundly sleeping dragon
[Music]
all of the evidence is piled up birds
really are dinosaurs
to conclude today's lesson here are some
of the most common questions I get asked
about dinosaurs with our Newfound
perspective we can now give some more
insightful answers
everyone always wants to know what the
biggest dinosaur was this is one place
where those fossil dinosaurs still have
their bird descendants beat you know
that it is likely to be a sauropod
probably something like Argentinosaurus
but what if someone asks you what's the
smallest dinosaur
now your answer can't just be based back
in the Mesozoic With The non-flying
Dinosaurs technically the smallest dinos
so far known is the minuscule bee
hummingbird weighing only about two
grams about the same as a dime
what if someone wants to know if we
could splice Dino and frog DNA to make a
dinosaur as they did in Jurassic Park
you can now put your knowledge to work
and answer frog genomes would never do
the trick all we need to do to make a
dinosaur is to manipulate the DNA of
living Dinosaurs the birds scientists
are already pushing at the limits of
this field not to recreate extinct
dinosaurs but to understand the genetic
underpinnings of the transition from
dinosaur to bird
if a friend asks you what's the fastest
dinosaur your answer might need a
follow-up do they mean the fastest
terrestrial Runner or the fastest flyer
if a terrestrial Runner you can quickly
rule out big extinct theropods like
T-Rex they were just too big to be very
fast you might compare and contrast
extinct and modern dinosaurs with
similar body plans and similar masses
maybe some of the smaller theropods
could have given a modern ostrich a run
for its money we estimate that like
ostriches at least a few of these
fleet-footed extinct dinos probably
topped out around 45 or 50 miles per
hour
however if your friend is thinking only
about movement then the hands down
winner is the modern flying dinosaur the
peregrine falcon which can die that
speeds more than 200 miles per hour
one question that my college students
always want to know the answer to what's
the smartest dinosaur you'll have to
answer this one honestly it's pretty
much impossible to know for sure how
intelligent different ancient dinosaurs
were but among living birds it would
probably be those problem-solving tool
using crows the language learning
parrots or the vocalization imitators
like the superb lyrebird
and my personal favorite
someone asks you do T-rex taste like
chicken you can confidently answer no
chicken tastes like T-Rex